as pistorius arrived in court he knew
he'd been spared the worst the judge
repeated her comments from Thursday
there was not enough evidence to prove
Pistorius intended to kill his
girlfriend reeva Steenkamp but she said
he had clearly broken the law she
settled on a lesser charge mr. Pistorius
please stand up the accused is found not
guilty and is discharged instead he is
found guilty of culpable homicide the
verdict supports pistorius's version of
the events that he mistook Steenkamp for
an intruder and in panic shot her
through the bathroom door the
prosecution accused Pistorius of murder
believing the fatal shooting was the
result of a lover's quarrel who are
disappointed that we did not get or
secure a conviction on premeditated
murder and also that there was an
acquittal on other two charges Pistorius
was acquitted on charges of illegal
possession of ammunition and firing a
pistol in his car but he was convicted
on a separate incident of illegally
firing a gun in a restaurant sentencing
is set for October 13th that means more
waiting for the victim's parents as well
hopefully for the parents he will get
just a few years
because it just shows that money can buy
Dutch doesn't sentence
historias has had his bail extended so
he's not going to prison yet he could
still face up to 15 years behind bars
but he could also just get a suspended
sentence and not go to prison at all